where am i God well we're trying to get
the shape of this and these accurate as
possible right so my very first step
before I put pen to actual graph is I
differentiate because I know it events
I'm gonna have to put the turning points
on this right if there are too many
points
so I've differentiated here and I've
said for stationary points or five where
the derivative is zero so that's where
I've gotten to solve that okay so I know
about two stationary points after and
these know more specifically well where
are they okay now it's easy to see them
when x equals zero Y is also equal to
zero so that's why I haven't put down
any working for that but when X is equal
to minus two I wasn't confident to do it
in my head so I just wanted to check out
the numbers okay now this is at four
okay so when you plot this this is minus
2 4 and the other one I said was the
origin 0 0 so now you know you can put
these two points on just like intercepts
as important places that you need to go
through so on the ground I'm not sure if
you can still see the original but add
these two positions these two stationary
points I draw a little horizontal line
okay that's just to make sure what I
actually connect up all the dots it has
the right curvature at that point and
it's smooth okay this is the kind of
situation that I want to avoid I've got
one at -2 4 or 1 and 0 and then as I
start to graph I drew my line down and
then I realize I'm too close and you get
a sort of like shop kind of shade
okay it shouldn't be like that it
shouldn't be served rigid you need to
have a more smooth curve okay so I put
them on I also label I mean even though
I haven't tested on either side you can
see by the values right this one is
above this one so this one will be the
max and this one will be the min okay so
that's why I can see I've labeled them
so okay you should distinguish between
them and then I had my intercepts and
after that that was it
so all I did was from here actually my
curve up so make sure I had the right
curvature on this side and then I
connected the dots that was it okay now
you mean you get this one this has got
an extra problem with her because I
think I mentioned this earlier
okay this doesn't factorize neatly
unlike unlike this okay something else I
forgot to mention before I get on to
this one if we've given you x squared
times X plus 3 right and we've given
this to you last year so you would have
known enough to say well this will have
two roots 0 and minus 3 but the tears
are not the same kind of room right we
would have given a special name to the
root idea we would have said it's a
double root it's like it goes there and
it just touches the minute it goes off
okay so a double root now you have a
better way to describe that right it
means you have a stationary point and
the root at the same time okay in other
words y equals 0 and dy 1 DX equals
coincide that's what we call it double
root ok just so you're connecting the
dots now let's come back to this one
because it doesn't factorize nicely ok I
perceive with my derivative because this
is still going to give me useful
information anyway okay so I solve it
this is where my stationary points are
going to be I just did some Y values so
I sub back into the original function
and here's my two stationary points
again you can guess you know apart from
the fact that if the coefficient makes
cubed is there so it's gonna increase
and go off into infinity so this one is
gonna be higher this one's gonna be
lower okay now also notice that this is
10 this is 6 and my interset my y
intercept is 8 it's right in between
right so you have this symmetry around
here now I want you to have a look at
your graph with your already drawn this
ok and check to see that if you were to
hide this axis down here and just look
up here it ought to look like an odd
function ok that's because this part VR
is an odd function and then the 8 just
moves it up that's all it's done ok so
if it doesn't look symmetrical around
here for instance one part looks higher
or in sort of skewed to one side you're
gonna have some issues
ok needs to be symmetrical so I've got
10 8 6 you can see the drop I don't know
what this value is and there's not
really a nicely way to find it because
like I said the cubic function is really
terrible so in this question you
okay but when you can't find it you
should okay